after he was shot he was still wagging
his tail such a loving dog cops killing
dogs like that is sadly not a rare
occurrence it's called Puppy side and
it's tragically common in America
officers are trained to shoot when they
feel threatened but many dogs have been
killed without posing any clear danger
and officers rarely face discipline for
it get off my property you shot kill my
dog there are thousands of known cases
of cops killing family pets but no one
knows for sure how often it happens the
online puppy side database set to do
document all of them but found it was
almost impossible due to fees local
governments charge for public records
requests and many departments more than
half of all shooting incidents involve
cops shooting dogs according to the
ASPCA and sometimes the police end up
endangering humans like the Arkansas
officer who tried to kill a tiny
Pomeranian but missed get back get
back so while dogs are a man's best
friend they're also the cop's favorite
target practice